este domingo se desarrolla en uruguay un
referéndum que según analistas políticos
determinará si el presidente luis
lacalle pou podrá o no continuar con sus
políticas de gobierno lacalle pou luego
de asumir en el 2020 presentó una ley de
urgente consideración cumpliendo con una
promesa electoral con 476 artículos la
oposición consideró que el uso de este
mecanismo era inconstitucional dado lo
extensa de esta ley y que el parlamento
cuenta con 90 días para analizarla y
votarla luego de aprobada la oposición
logró el número de firmas suficientes
para impugnar
135 artículos de la misma que consideran
daña la democracia y los derechos de los
uruguayos entre los artículos impugnados
se encuentran varios sobre la seguridad
pública
y regulan la legítima defensa de los
policías se generan más extensas
condenas en algunos delitos y también se
regula el derecho de manifestación y
reunión algo que fue cuestionado por
naciones unidas otro de los artículos
impugnados se refieren a la educación
allí donde los docentes perdieron la
posibilidad de representación en áreas
ejecutivas
también se están impugnando artículos
que se refieren a la política fiscal a
la administración de las empresas
públicas y a la fijación de precios
el voto es obligatorio hoy en uruguay
para este referéndum las últimas
encuestas indican que el número de
indecisos era muy alto para que se logre
el cip a la impugnación de estos 135
artículos esta papeleta deberá obtener
la mitad más uno de los votos los votos
en blancos cuentan hacia el no